To some,
he was the very embodiment of evil,
the psychopathic incarnation of the devil himself.
To others,
he was a god fearing defender of the faith,
courageously standing up to the feared Ottoman Empire in his time,
he was known as Vlad the impaler thanks to his favorite method of executing
people today,
though we remember him as the real life inspiration for bram stoker's infamous
prince of darkness.
In this week's biographics,
we discover the gruesome truth about the real flat Dracula,
Vlad Dracula future prints of where they here was born in either November or
December of 14,
31 in the northern Romanian state.
If we lay here,
his father flap.
The second was to become ruler of flakier.
In the year of his second son's birth,
Vlad senior joined in 90 society known as the order of the dragons.
Upon his induction,
he was given the surname draggle,
which is a derivative of Drac,
meaning dragon in ancient Romanian.
However,
in the modern Romanian language,
this means devil.
His son was given the name for some of that being dracula,
the world of land was born into.
It was a violent one,
consumed with disputes over territory and rulership,
family name and Ana were the most important thing,
something which was drummed into the boy from the start.
He also understood that the goal was to push the boundaries of the empire
regardless of the cost,
the order of the Dragon,
which Vlad scene he became a part of,
was committed to defending Christianity against the haters.
Ottoman Turks at the time of his son's birth,
Vad.
The second served as a guard commander in the mountain passes and we're like
here,
we don't actually know who've lads,
mother was when Vlad was born.
His father was married to princess and nature,
but he also had a string of mistresses and anyone could have given birth to the
future.
Dracula lands formative years were spent in ct,
so IRA,
when his father ascended to the throne of weather here in 1436,
he brought Vlad and his younger brother Ragu to live in the royal court in the
capital.
The boys.
It would have been educated at home by Greek and Roman scholars who their father
had brought in from Constantinople.
They would have busied themselves with learning the rudiments of mathematics,
geography,
science,
and languages including old church,
slavonic,
German,
and Latin,
that's their privileged upbringing,
was rudely interrupted when their father was ousted as real of a rival group who
were in league with the Hungarians.
Glad senior built an alliance with the Ottoman Sea,
agreed to help him regain his throne on the proviso that he paid tribute to
Sultan macramed the seconds and so that he leave his two sons at the Ottoman
court as a guarantee of his loyalty labs had no choice and the two boys were
seized and made prisoners,
although relatively well treated,
the boys were able to observe the Turkish use of Taran as an instrument in order
to achieve ends.
This was something which Vlad would use to great effect nature in his own life
while in the Ottoman court.
So the boys were able to further their education being instructed in logic,
the Turkish language and the teachings of the Koran.
They were also given lessons in horsemanship and warfare.
The two brothers differ markedly and their attitude towards their captivity.
Roger,
either younger brother,
he accepted the situation and embraced his new life and the teachings that came
with it,
it would eventually converted Islam and to service in the Ottoman court.
Vlad,
however,
resistant as every turn,
despite constant punishments for is certainly attitudes with the assistance of
the Turks.
Lads senior was able to regain his throne,
but this wasn't something that lasted in 14.
40 seven Hungarian backs,
rebels attacked again,
forcing Vlad and his oldest son Messier the second to fleet both were eventually
captured and put to death.
The next in line to the throne of winter here was vlad the third,
his older brother,
but he had become a monk and lived in a monastery.
This left Vlad who is now 16 as the rightful heir to the throne.
Despite his obstinate and see the Turks had grown fond of the teenager.
They vowed to help him regain his throne,
which they did with an overthrow of the rebel ruler in 1448.
As soon as the Ottomans left,
however,
the Hungarians were back and within two months flat was forced to flee to
Moldova for the next three years.
He lived there under the protection and tutelage of his uncle Prince Bogdan the
seconds,
but when Bogdan was assassinated in 1450,
one flat again,
fled this time along with his cousin print steven,
the two young men ended up in Transylvania where they came onto the mentorship
of a Hungarian warrior named John,
who knew Yardi.
He was a power broker who was fiercely opposed to the Ottoman Empire from Yardi,
had originally supported the new ruler of a man by the name of gladys.
Love the seconds,
but the relationship it quickly disintegrated.
This was thanks largely to that slavs appeasement of the Turks when Vladislav
invaded in several villages in Transylvania.
When yardies patients,
it's simply gave out,
he looks young blast to take back the throne that rightfully belonged to him.
In the same year,
14,
53,
the holy Roman city of Constantinople fell to the Ottoman Turks.
It's now appeared as if the whole of Europe was theirs for the taking.
The securing of way here became more important than ever,
and in 14,
56 land led an army into the area.
He meets the army of Lattice love on the field of battle,
ended up killing the usurper in hand to hand combat with the death of gladys.
Slava.
Vlad was restored power as the ruler of Lakeea over the next six years,
he would rule with an unprecedented bloodlust that would cement his name forever
in the annals of merciless monarchs,
having secured the throne of Lakeea for himself,
God sends a portion of his army over the border to help his cousin,
steven,
to secure the throne of Moldova.
When this was accomplished,
the two cousins held sway over a large swath of the Balkans,
proving a powerful strong hold against the tax lads now set his mind on revenge.
He had his spies go and find the names of any nobles who had even been remotely
involved in the plot to overthrow his father.
Having collected a list of names of lads invited the men to an Easter feast
along with their families,
but as soon as the traders arrived,
they were arrested.
The older among them were impaled venom there,
right in front of their families.
Those who are younger,
we're forced into slavery,
laboring to rebuild Vlads causal.
When this job was done,
the they were all killed vlads treatments of the traitors to his father's reign.
It was just the beginning.
He next proceeded to enforce his own stringent moral code on the entire
population.
Any deviation was met with unthinkable cruelty.
He seemed to be especially concerned with female chastity.
Any woman who lost her virginity prior to marriage or who defiled the marriage
bed would be impaled with the insertion points being the vagina.
More often than not,
their breasts would also be cut off with a man with whom they had committed
fornication.
Being forced to eat them.
Labs also has a hatred of beggars considering them to be existing off the hard
work of others.
It is said that he once invited all the baggers in with her to a massive feast
in a centrally located,
wouldn't hold one day at Eaton,
do their full.
He is said to have ordered the doors bolted in the building,
set on fire.
In this way,
he is said to have read his realm of the scourge of poverty
on the international scene.
The ultimate threads was becoming more ominous.
In 1460,
Pope Pius the second held a congress that man to her initially calling for a new
crusade to reclaim constantinople and push the Ottomans back to the desert.
The crusade was to last for three years and will be led by Mathias Covinas.
He was the son of John in Yardi,
who had been killed during an invasion of Serbia.
Martinez,
made a tour of European kingdoms seeking support for the enterprise.
The only ruler who gave a positive response was flat.
Dracula overlay here determines to hold his kingdom safe from the texts.
He formed an alliance with Mathias veinous,
the Ottomans,
meanwhile,
well aware of the lack of support for this new crusade.
Sultan Mac mid the second seized the advantage by capturing the last independent
Serbian city smatter Rovio.
During this campaign,
the Hungarian general.
Now Holly says Lagi was taken captive.
This general was knowns of lads having helps put down a revolt in 15,
48.
When Vlad heard that he had been sought in half his blood boils and he became
more committed than ever to teaching the Ottomans a lesson that they would never
forget.
The ultimate empire extended degrees in 40 slash 61 when the we grew surrendered
without putting up any defense.
Now,
both Corinth and the capital of Mr were ruled by the Turks.
The sultan also had his sights on here.
He declared it to be part of the Ottoman Empire as song she sent envoys,
Div Lance Castle in order to collect a tribute of 10,000 buckets along with 500
men to be taken into.
The TAC is Shami,
but the sultan had underestimated the young ruler
when the sultans,
envoys,
refused to lift that Tibetans as a sign of respect to him.
Vlad became enraged and times is God's drive nails through their turbans and
into their skulls the incredible assault and responded by sending his army
across the Danube in order to seize the men and bring them back to become a part
of his army.
Lot centers forces to the area to grab any tax that could be found.
They will soon impaled on red hot stakes towards the end of 14,
61 bladder wrote to the salt and informing him that he could not afford to pay a
tribute,
but that he was coming to Constantinople and was ready to negotiate.
Macramed was aware of of laddered already aligned himself with the crusade,
so we decided to take the way he and ruler who her dad to murder his invoice by
force.
He sent one of his generals along with a thousand strong cavalry to meet with
land with the intention of ambushing him,
but Vlad got wind of the plan that's put into operation is I an ambush as the
approaching tax.
We're negotiating their way through a narrow traverse that and army they
attacked.
It hasn't been reported.
That vlans attack was one of the first instances where gun powder was used.
Apparently two deadly effects.
The dogs work ells with many of them suffering of lance favorite torture,
and that was of course impalements with his blood.
Now,
up flat took his army across the Danube River where they attacked Ottoman
controlled areas in Bulgaria between Saudi or in the Black Sea,
were given advanced,
do fortify towns and use his skills in the Turkish language.
Do encourage the gods do open the gates,
then is Ami would pour in from over the horizon that would then go into a
killing frenzy.
Slaughtering every Turkish man,
woman or child that he could find.
Over a period of two weeks,
he lead his army over an area of 500 miles,
carrying around 23,000 people in February of 14,
62 vlad ropes in glowing terms to Mathias covinas about what he had accomplished
in red.
I've killed peasant men and women,
young and old who lived at oblong sits on and Novo Selo where the Danube flows
into the sea up to [inaudible],
which is located near chillier from the lower Danube to such places as some of
us and Gagan.
We Killed Twenty 3,884 tax without counting those,
and we burned in homes or the tax whose heads were cut by our soldiers.
Thus,
your highness,
you must know I've broken the piece and outraged Sultan ordered his grand vizier
Mac mode with 18,000 troops to destroy a port in well Lakeea Code Brailler.
This force was intercepted by Vlad and this 30,000 strong army.
The Turks were utterly defeated with only 8,000 of them surviving these quick
five victories and flat,
a heroic reputation throughout Europe.
Even the pope praised him at the same time,
his reputation as the impaler king served to intimidate the Turkish people,
many of whom plans the European part of the Ottoman Empire for Anatolia in
response to the slaughter and the fear that Vlad had caused amongst his people.
Salton macramed abandoned his campaign and Greece and turns his attention to the
problem.
He gathered an army of 150,000 people with the sole mission of finding and
killing.
Vlad.
The Sultan had already promised the rulership of relay here to of lands younger
brother Randy with himself after the head,
the Salton set out to find and kill flat
payless
force of around 13,000.
We're not saying the hugely outnumbered.
They were also hopelessly out classed as far as weaponry was concerned.
They carried only launces and daggers,
whereas the text had in their midst squadrons of deadly arches along with
powerful siege and muscle weaponry.
Despite this Vlad was able to inflict major casualties upon the sultans forces,
he followed a scorched earth policy as he moved away from the approaching.
Tax Wells were poisoned with entire populations,
including animals being evacuated,
also engaged in guerrilla fighting tactics.
Hit and run.
Raids were made on the sultan's army and as a primitive type of germ warfare was
also utilized were men who were afflicted with the bubonic plague,
was sent in Turkish towns,
do in fact as many people as possible.
The tactic works with the plague spreading to the sultans.
Men in the end though,
the efforts of lads,
men were no more than an irritant to the vastly superior Turkish army.
Steadily.
They moved on getting ever closer to the castle when they arrived there and does
24,000 men,
strong army were holed up in the mountain refuge just outside of the city of
that who was now faced with an encircled by the Turks,
which would eventually forces army into starvation did something quite
extraordinary even for him leaving his men behind in the mountains.
He disguised himself and walked directly into the Turkish army encampments.
He quickly determines the position of the sultans tent.
He founds out that the sultan had given the order for his men to remain in their
tents at night in order to prevent panic in the event of an attack even quietly
slipped out of the camp and returned back to his own men,
lads,
and help set about planning a surprise attack on the sultan's army.
It was his personal intention to enter.
The sultans tends to drive a knife through Mac meds heart on the night of June
the 17,
14,
62,
he divided his forces into two man's then attacked from both the north and the
south.
The Turks were caught off guard allowing the attackers to inflect heavy losses
within an hour of savage fighting.
More than 15,000 Turks were slaughtered at a cost of some five thousands of lads
men.
He himself succeeded in entering the tents that he had previously picked out.
The only problem was that he had selected the wrong tense and founds no salt and
insight.
A daybreak flags cooled off the attack and his men melted back into the
mountains.
The sultan was so despondent that he pulled back and was prepared to retreat all
the way back across the Denewb.
However,
he was convinced by his generals that success with still within their grasp and
so he led his men into the capital city.
When they arrived in [inaudible],
the tilex founds an abandoned city.
They also found the remains of 20,000 Turkish soldiers killed in previous
conflicts and impaled on steaks.
At this site,
the sultan is said to have remarked,
a man who has done such things is worth much with nothing to do in the empty
city the sultan installed,
do as the new ruler of delay here,
and then turned and began to retrace his steps back to the denewb rather than
the younger brother of labs.
Now I'm talking as forces and circled vlads castle and located on a cliff just
outside of the city lands.
First wife within the castle legend has it that she found to feed herself to the
fishes rather than full to the tax.
Apparently she threw herself from the walls into the river below.
Rather,
you set about solidifying his position.
Meanwhile,
the Sultan had taken his army airway to brayleigh where the town was destroyed
and hundreds were killed.
Vlad knew that he had to regroup and gather a larger force if he was have any
chance of regaining control of relay.
Here he made his way to Hungary where he sought the help of his ally.
Macias Cornice Matteo's appeared to give us support,
even making battle plans with labs.
However,
covertness had secretly turned against his old ally.
You organized the plans,
you ambush vlad.
The impaler was taken as this prison prisoner.
The reason for Matty as this change of loyalty has been debated now for
centuries with the consensus being that he wanted to become holy Roman emperor
and knew that an end to hostilities with the tax was needed before they can
become a reality land spent the next four years as a prisoner and hungry.
During this time,
he converted to Catholicism.
He also met king metastasis,
cousin having softened his attitude towards this prisoner.
Mateus allowed the to to marry.
Apparently he was released just prior to the ceremony land and his new wife were
given a house.
It passed.
It was under strict instructions not to return to.
We're like,
yeah,
this.
He had no intention of giving up on the crown that still rightly belongs to him.
He secretly collaborations with a former military commander.
They managed to gather together and Ami consisting of a mixture of Hungarian
Transylvanian well Adrian and Moldavia and forces of land set out with his
makeshift Ami in the middle of 1476 by now.
His younger brother Randy would died and they had been replaced by Prince busop.
The elder before flatted even God photography shared the Saab and his army had
flat.
Vlad was placed on the throne and the army largely dissolved.
Labs was back in power,
but he lacked a strong army.
In fact,
he only had around 4,000 men to draw upon,
so when the tax returns two months after his retaking of the throne,
he was soundly defeated.
The exact details surrounding his death are a master of some debates.
Most scholars agree that he was killed while fighting the techs in early 14,
77,
a contemporary Turkish chronicle a recorded that the tax killed and decapitated
him,
sending his head back to Constantinople.
There it is,
said to have been presented in honey and to put on display so that everyone
could see that the graduate impaler was really finally debt.
It is estimated that Vlans,
legacy of execution methods included more than 20,000 impalements,
5,000 beheadings,
10,000 burnings at stake,
tend to x.
You had nails driven through that turbans and at least one who was boiled alive
and then cannibalized,
yet in his home country of Romania flat is seen as a hero.
Here's an important national figure,
a god fearing it.
Who stood up to the Ottoman Empire?
Well,
I guess it all depends on your perspective,
so I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel for brand new biographies every Monday
and every Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel that's called today I found out it's sort of like
biographics,
but way more broad on that channel.
We get deep into all of the details on all sorts of interesting stuff.
Check it out through the link on the screen now,
but if you're looking for something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the archives or today?
Found out video over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.